CAMPAIGN EITHER DENYING IT OR
BLAMING THE MEDIA FOR IT.
AND IT DOESN’T HELP.
IT ACTUALLY WELL, IT DOES HELP,
IT HELPS THE RUSSIANS.
>> Sean: HERE WITH REX AND
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR TREY GOWDY.
FOUR SEPARATIONS FROM FBI TO MY
HOUSE AND TELL, BIPARTISAN
SENATE INVESTIGATION AND THE
MUELLER REPORT.
NOW WITH ALL THE TALK ABOUT THE
RULE OF LAW, THEY AVOID
ESPIONAGE AND TOP-SECRET
INFORMATION ON A SERVER, BLEACH
BOOT, DELETIONS, SUBPOENAED
EMAILS AND THE REAL RUSSIAN
DOSSIER BOUGHT AND PAID FOR LEAK
TO THE MEDIA PARTS OF IT BEFORE
THE ELECTION, BUT USED TO DENY
CARTER PAGE CIVIL LIBERTIES AND
SPY ON A CAMPAIGN TRANSITION
TEAM PRESIDENCY.
HOW COME THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT
THOSE THINGS?
>> YEAH, SEAN, WE SPENT TWO
YEARS TO TELL US THAT THERE IS
NO EVIDENCE.
AT LEAST TWO YEARS FOR MUELLER
TO TELL US THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION.
IT TOOK 2 MINUTES THIS TIME TO
FIND OUT THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE.
AS SOON AS A REPUBLICAN ASKED
THE BRIEFER AND DECLASSIFIED
HOUSE IN TOW A BRIEFING FROM A
WIDE EVIDENCE DO YOU HAVE TO
SUPPORT THAT ASSESSMENT?
THE ANSWER WAS NOT.
PRAISE THE LORD IT TOOK TWO
YEARS LESS, 2 MINUTES FOR OVER A
YEAR, WE WERE LECTURED BY THE
D.C. MEDIA AND THE DEMOCRATS.
NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW.
TO REMEMBER THAT, SEAN?
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE WE HEARD NO
ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW APPARENTLY
WHOEVER LEAKED CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION OF ADAM SCHIFF’S
COMMITTEE.
WHAT THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
NEEDS TO GIVE TO IS TO STOP
REAPING SOMEONE WHO HAS A
HISTORY AND IS AN EPIDEMIC
LEAKER.
QUIT READING IT.
>> Sean: OKAY, I HAVE A
QUESTION.
SO SCHIFF LIGHT TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
DEVIN NUNES TOLD THE TRUTH AND
WE HAVE BOTH OF THEIR DOCUMENTS,
SCHIFF LIED TO.
WHY DOES HE NOT GET HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR LENGTH THE WAY
HE DID TO THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
WHEN HE KNEW BETTER?
>> UNFORTUNATELY, SEAN IT IS NOT
AGAINST THE LAW TO LIE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THERE SHOULD BE A CONSEQUENCE
AND I HOPE THE REPUBLIC OF
CALIFORNIA WILL REMEMBER IT COME
NOVEMBER.
BUT IT IS A DIRTY LITTLE SECRET,